SAL YANEZ: Hi, Kellee.
First of all, thank you very
much for being here with us.
I think your story is
very inspirational.
And now with Hispanic
Heritage Month,
it's very useful to hear
about your experience.
So why don't we start with
listening about your story.
How did this girl who
was born in Venezuela
grow up to be president and
co-founder of thatgamecompany,
have your own games, changed
all these paradigms about how
the video game industry
thinks about games,
potentially putting a
little bit of art in it,
and how you ended up here?
Can you walk us
through your story?
And what was the key
inspiration that you had?
How were you thinking about when
you did different maneuvers?
Especially being at
USC, doing an MFA,
and then coming back into
the video game industry.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah, I'll try
and do the highlights, maybe.
I'm sure we'll dig
into points of it.
So my father, first, is Cuban.
He left it with his family
in 1960, as many did.
And while he was in the
United States, met my mother.
They were in Virginia.
He worked in
software engineering
and also did a lot of management
in the business side of it.
And so he would often work
with the Latin American arms
of various software and
technology companies.
And that's how my family ended
up in Venezuela for a few years
during which I was born.
We then, shortly thereafter,
came back to Virginia.
I grew up in Richmond,
Virginia, and didn't
know any other Latinas.
I was trying to think.
I don't know that there were
any other Latinas at my school.
I definitely grew up
in a pretty traditional
suburban American
neighborhood, right
in the middle between the
city of Richmond and the farms
outside.
And not a lot of people leave
Virginia to go to college,
but for some reason,
I had it in my mind
that I was going to leave
as soon as I graduated
from high school.
And I really focused
on going to New York.
That's where I wanted to go.
And so while I was
in high school--
I had been developing
my whole life--
but really gravitated
towards the arts
and all mediums of art.
But in high school, I think it
started really focusing around
performing arts.
And so I applied to the
New York University Tisch
School of the Arts
for theater, and that
was my ticket out of Virginia.
And looking back, I
think some of that
had to do with just
being an outsider
from the very beginning.
My husband and I
talk a lot about it
because he's from Toronto,
and loves Toronto,
and grew up there, and
feels a lot affinity there.
And how is it that you
grow up in a place,
and yet, you don't feel like
you're really from there.
So then in New York,
I really started
gravitating towards
original works, which
more and more
started incorporating
interactive media and digital
media into the performances.
And so I would become
the de facto person
in charge of that stuff
because I was in the arts,
but then I also was very
comfortable with computers
because we always
had one at my house,
and my dad worked
in that business.
And it was something
that was never taboo
or that I was discouraged from.
So a couple years after
graduating from NYU,
I decided to, oh, maybe
I'll focus on that,
really become specialized
in interactive media
and performance.
And that's what brought
me to the University
of Southern California and
their MFA in interactive media
program.
So this other throughline
through all that
is video games and
playing video games.
But it's like another place
for outsiders, I guess,
and also a space in which--
all through college,
I was in college right at
the height of "GoldenEye."
That's what you did with people.
But that was one of the first
times, also, it was all guys,
and none of my
girlfriends did it.
And that was really
interesting and weird,
and that continued after school.
So it was something
that I enjoyed.
It was part of my life.
But never thought about
who made a video game,
or how they went about it,
or that it was something
that I would do.
And then my first
year at USC, I had
this course in the
history of play,
taught by Tracy Fullerton,
who now chairs the program.
And it looked at the
history of game design
not only within the context
of digital video games
but throughout human history,
and the role of play and game
design in culture.
And I think that really opened
my eyes up to game design
as a medium through which
you would communicate.
That, coupled within the
school's general philosophy
of rapid iteration
and prototyping,
The program is housed within
the School of Cinematic Arts,
so it really took this
storytelling focus on it.
I'm sorry.
I feel like this
keeps dangling off.
Is it OK?
You can hear OK, right?
OK.
Sorry.
So yeah, thinking about it
as a communicative medium.
And instead of starting with
this bullet point list of we're
making this kind of
game, we're going
to make an RPG, that means
it has this kind of mechanic,
and it's going to be
set in this world,
and our twist is you're a
girl, or whatever that is,
it was really
starting with, what's
a story that you want to tell?
And now let's use this
process of rapid iteration
and prototyping to discover
game mechanics that elicit that.
And yeah, so I just started
dedicating everything to that.
I realize it was the medium I
had been looking for all along.
It was really a combination
of those interests in science
and technology as well as
the arts and communication,
and also anthropology
and psychology.
And the people in it were and
are of that like-mindedness.
So for the first time, when
I went to my first Game
Developers Conference
that same year,
it was like a one-two
punch in getting me
on board with game design.
So having my eyes open to
game design as a medium,
and then going to the
Game Developers Conference
and feeling like I was
a part of this tribe,
that these were my people.
And that really energized
me, and so I just
started trying to work on as
many game projects as possible.
And that's what led
me to collaborating
with my fellow student
Jenova Chen on a student
project called "Cloud."
OK, is this good?
SAL YANEZ: Yeah.
KELLEE SANTIAGO:
We're getting up
to-- OK, not too much,
not too little, hopefully.
So "Cloud," it's funny to think
about now because, for us, it
was really an
experiment in thinking,
could we take this philosophy
of our program, this viewpoint
of, really, games
as storytelling,
use that to communicate a
story that was not typically
told in commercially
accepted video games,
but make something that would
appeal to an equally, if not
broader, audience?
The idea being that we were
growing up and maturing,
and there weren't games
there for us anymore.
That games with deep story
also required so much time
that we didn't have.
And the converse of that was
really casual, shallow games.
And so could we create games
that both deeply resonated
with people, but also
recognized constraints
around time and money?
And "Cloud" was
this game in which
you played as a boy who
was trapped in the hospital
and daydreamed he could
fly through the clouds.
And the idea was to
elicit this feeling
like you were a kid daydreaming
and looking at the sky.
And I think there was
another school that
had this story of how their
game for another festival
had been downloaded 1,000
times or something like that.
And we were like,
oh, we could do that.
Because you really
just put them online,
and people downloaded them
to judge them for festivals.
Or probably not.
Usually, we would send CD-ROMs.
That's how you did it.
But we made the website, so if
someone happens to check it out
at one of these festivals, they
can then go play it themselves.
That would be awesome.
And then within three months,
we had over 300,000 downloads
from all over the world.
It was extremely
organic, extremely viral.
And it made us feel like we
were really on to something.
This was something
that people wanted.
So "Cloud" was created
under this grant
that EA had provided the school.
And so as part of
that grant project,
we were to pitch
to EA as though we
were going to make "Cloud"
into a full console title.
But as a result
of this exercise,
Jenova and I had
this full pitch deck
about what it would look
like if we created a company,
and we had done all
this thinking about it.
And we got a lot of
feedback from EA.
That was extremely useful.
And one of the points
of feedback that we got
was, hey, there's this new thing
called digital distribution.
And those games can be smaller.
You don't have to make these
multimillion dollar projects
anymore.
And that will be a
barrier for you guys
because you don't have any
experience in the industry.
So maybe if you
scaled this down,
think about making
a small version that
could be digitally distributed
at a smaller price point, that
would be more acceptable.
And that's what we did.
And then sure enough, Sony
was really into that idea
because, unbeknownst to
the world at that point,
they were planning on
PlayStation Network
the next year.
And they also had an idea about
using digital distribution
to create high quality unique
content that wouldn't get made
otherwise, and to take
advantage of these smaller price
points and a willingness to have
shorter experiences than you
would when you buy a
$50, $60 disk title.
So we joined forces with
them in a three-game deal
to develop three titles
for PlayStation Network.
And we did "Flow,"
"Flower," and then "Journey"
was our last one, under this
umbrella of thatgamecompany.
The mission of
thatgamecompany was
to create experiences
that would push
the boundaries of video games
as a communicative medium.
So every game that we did,
we started with a point of,
first of all, what's
something that hasn't
been done in games before?
But also, what are we motivated
to talk about and say?
And then going on a long
journey ourselves to figure out,
OK, what's the game that
really captures that feeling?
And one of the things I'm
probably the most proud
of with all three games
is I think no matter
when it is I'm looking at them,
and if I look at any of them
today, they're all
still super weird to me,
in a way that I can't believe
we got away with making
that on a major console.
And that then lots of people
played it and were really
into those titles.
I'm very proud that we
took that opportunity
that we had to go out on a limb
and that we just really did
that.
And we kind of said, well,
whether it's successful or not,
we're at least going
to really try this out.
And I feel like we did
that on every project.
SAL YANEZ: Wow.
That's extremely interesting.
Thanks for sharing
your story, by the way.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah.
SAL YANEZ: And I think what
stands out the most to me
is how you were talking about
you got to this place thanks
to a perfect combination
of several factors.
You had passion for media.
You had a hobby for video games.
You had the family influence
for systems and computers.
You had the school influence
with historic gaming.
And then you started going
and pivoting from this place
where you felt like a
stranger to this place
where you felt
like you belonged.
And you started
finding this community,
and that became very
powerful for you.
And I think that working
with that community
allowed you to explore
outside your comfort zone
and start thinking
about video games
as art, as communicating a
story line through video games.
And I think that's
really powerful.
And it comes thanks
to all that background
that allowed you to go out
there and explore that.
Can you tell us how
that specific mindset
started of video games as art?
Because many people
here, we don't generally
think of video games as art.
Once you start
understanding why, then it
starts making sense.
Can you walk us through why
you consider video games art?
And how did you
start with this idea?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah.
Well, fundamentally,
it comes down
to-- did you play video games
when you were growing up?
SAL YANEZ: Yeah.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: What was
a game that you really--
SAL YANEZ: Well, I
played "GoldenEye,"
"Mario Kart," "Smash Brothers."
So I'm not a big gamer, but
I did spend a few hundred
hours in those games.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah,
so maybe some of it
is trying to validate
that time spent.
I think there is
an element where
I like to think anyone who's
making that argument, including
myself, it's because there has
been at least one game that's
impacted you in a way that
any other medium would.
So it's hard to negate that
or put a divide somehow
between the experience
I had with-- I'm
trying to think of
any of them, even
"Zelda 64" and the emotional
journey of that story.
I know a lot of
other people my age,
it's "Final Fantasy 7,"
which is the hero's journey.
And the impact that had
on them and their psyche,
it just feels similar
to other art forms.
So we say that.
But the other component
of it is then, really,
I think formalizing the
vocabulary and ideas
around that when I
was at grad school.
And within the game developer
community as a whole,
I think that's a large
thrust of the work
that we do as a
community, is really
understanding what is
codifying and trying
to put vocabulary around this.
That professor,
Tracy Fullerton, was
part of a whole academic
movement which is really
captured in her book, "Game
Design Workshop," which
is based on this idea I think
coming from a time when there
was this idea that game
designers were just wizards
and you could do it
or you couldn't do it.
You were either good at
it or not good at it.
But there was a whole other
subculture saying, well,
we think that we can put
some structure around this
and put some ideas to this,
that we could teach anyone
how to do it.
You can at least make
someone a good designer
and maybe make a good
designer a great designer
through this process.
So I think that was hugely
formative and really
solidifying, for me, the idea
that games have the potential
to be artistic.
I don't think all
games are artistic,
but I don't think all television
is art or all films are art.
But is it capable of that?
Yes, it's definitely
capable of that.
There's a vocabulary.
There is a language.
You can use it to speak to
other people through it.
SAL YANEZ: That's great.
So when I think about
video games and so on,
I think that there can be many
different components of it.
One can be the
graphics part, that I
can see graphics being art.
You can think about
the music, the music
in a video game being are.
But you're referring
specifically
to the storytelling, to how you
connect with other audiences.
And the example that
you bring is Zelda.
It has a storytelling to it, but
it's a very complicated story.
So when you compare
it against "Cloud,"
this kid who just dreams about
going through the clouds,
or a video game where
you're just the wind
and you're going
through the mountains,
it's a very different story.
And you mentioned
it even now, I'm
surprised that so many
people got into it.
What do you think made so
many people get into it?
It's definitely art,
but art is not always
appreciated right away.
It doesn't become as viral
as your games have become.
What do you think made your
game special as opposed
to other games who might
be trying storytelling
in this novel way but
didn't succeed as you did.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah, I
mean, I think a lot of games
require a lot of
players in order
to get that story out of it.
I mean, accessibility as a
whole was really important to us
and continues to be
important to all of us.
And so how could
we remove barriers?
How could we create experiences
that really invited people
into them as opposed to
punishing them for not doing
the things we want them to do?
So not requiring a
lot of time in order
to even grasp the
story I think is
a barrier that we removed there.
Controls, "Cloud," actually
had really weird controls,
because we were
trying to make ones
that were more accessible
than your average PC game.
We failed at it on
"Cloud." it was something
that we took into our
work on PlayStation
and iterated over
time and every project
in trying to really
remove those barriers.
I have many friends who pick
up the controller in any
of our games and they
almost are sweating.
Oh my god, what am
I supposed to do?
It's OK.
Nothing's going
to happen to you.
You can figure it out.
It's all right.
You have time and there's
nothing coming out after you.
So yeah, trying to think about
not just making a game easier.
Difficulty is a barrier,
but there actually
are these other
barriers that almost
are psychological
to many people when
they approach a video game.
SAL YANEZ: Great.
And so just building
on that, when
you were thinking about
launching a new game,
and you want to adjust the
difficulty, the controls,
every single aspect
of the game, how
do you think about it when it's
such a new way of doing gaming?
Because you can't really compare
the controls against a fighting
game or something like that.
And even how people think
about it and they get engaged,
it also varies.
So how do you do it?
Did you start with
your small community
and then build up from there?
And if so, were you concerned?
How did you tackle the
obstacles that the market
might be different from
the small group designing
this game?
KELLEE SANTIAGO:
Yeah, play testing
is really, really critical.
And for us, we would
do it every two weeks
from the very
beginning of a project,
because we would start
with this very vague idea.
Like with "Journey," it was,
make an online multiplayer
console game that left
you with a renewed
sense of faith in humanity.
There's a lot that
could fall under that,
and so you just start
throwing things at the wall.
And it's very painful.
I think one of the biggest
mistakes game designers make
is not doing that.
And it's something that
everyone talks about.
But it's hard to watch people
play this thing that is ugly
and you know isn't
good but it's so useful
to get that feedback on it.
And yeah, I always
start with what's
called friends and
family playtests
and bring in even
more than just friends
and families but limiting
it to close advisors
who were also usually game
developers who I found
were very articulate.
So they could hear
what is that goal
and then how is our experience
aligning with that goal or not.
Then maybe opening it
up to friends and family
and then opening
up to a broad pool.
I mean doing very traditional
like user testing, focus
testing style sessions
with our games.
But at the end, I always felt
like-- I mean, especially
with "Journey" and
being an online game,
we didn't do an
online beta, really.
We did one limited.
So we didn't know
how many people
were always going to be
on together, for instance.
Those kind of questions
we had to launch
with them being unanswered.
And for me, it was,
do I think that we
made the game that articulated
the original goals we set out
to do?
Yes, OK, then I
think it's a success,
and then everything else happens
outside and I can't control it.
SAL YANEZ: Well, in
that very specific case
for "Journey," it sounds like
there were a lot of things
that you did different,
maybe based on the experience
that you had before.
So can you talk a little
bit about whether you
think that was part of
the success of "Journey?"
So when you compare it
against "Flow," "Flower,"
or even "Cloud," "Journey"
was a lot more successful
but it sounds that it's the one
where you didn't do the beta.
You didn't do a lot of testing.
Did you just decide to
go for the storytelling
and answer the question, am
I creating the product that I
want to create?
Do you think that
that's what generated
the success of "Journey?"
And if so, if you were going
to launch another game,
is that what you would do again?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Well,
we still get a lot
of testing with "Journey."
We just didn't do a full
online test with it.
But I don't know.
Whenever there's something
that's really successful,
it's really easy to
go back and think
you're reverse engineering it.
I do think there is an element.
Like in "Journey,"
it is first of all,
it's the hero's
journey structure
that came from, again,
this idea of creating
games that would resonate
with a wide group of people.
And then saying, oh
here's Joseph Campbell
and all his research
on hero's journey.
That's a story
that has resonated
with a wide group of people
over thousands of years.
What if we took it
into a video game?
But then, also, you were
playing as this avatar which
you weren't in our
previous games, really,
this sort of human-like being.
I think that possibly
resonated more
with the core PlayStation
audience, at least
at that time.
So yeah, I mean, there was
always a part of our process
that was understanding
who our core audience was,
which I think is
really helpful and not
something many people
maybe pick up on, as far as
what we were doing, or what I
think is still really critical.
Which is, there is this
story you want to tell,
but having impact
is this process
of thinking of like who is
your initial core audience
and radiating out from there.
And because we had an
exclusive deal with Sony,
we knew our audience was
going to be this PlayStation 3
audience.
That fundamentally was who
we were locked to at launch.
And if we don't
resonate with them,
it's not going to have that
ripple effect outwards.
So we deliberately made choices
around what it would look like.
And of course, Sony
having some input on that
as far as their goals
for what looks like
and feels like a polished
PlayStation experience.
SAL YANEZ: OK.
Did they have a lot of
influence in the game, then?
Were they actively
involved in that one?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: So
for the most part, no.
They're very hands
off as a studio
with their external developers.
But I think, the
positive influence of it
is that we all were kids
straight out of school
and we had no experience
doing commercial games.
And they really pushed
us in understanding
what it meant to make
a high quality console
title, which is very different
than making a student project.
There are a lot of
growing pains along that.
Yeah, growing pains is probably
the best way to describe it.
SAL YANEZ: OK.
So it sounds like you
as a group learned a lot
from that experience.
And thinking about
the group, I would
like to go back to something
that you said earlier about how
at the beginning you were
feeling like an outsider.
And then there was a point where
you felt like you belonged.
Thinking about the
framing of this talk,
we're doing this as part
of Hispanic Heritage Month,
I would like to ask you how
do you find that community?
Being a Hispanic woman in
the video game industry,
how did you navigate that?
Were there any
obstacles that you
needed to tackle that
you want to highlight?
And if so, after
that, how did you
build that community that
you felt like you belonged?
But I think it's very
important for everybody
here to understand how do you
find that place, that community
where you feel like you belong?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Mhm.
Yeah, that's huge.
So I don't know anyone
else's experience but my own.
I guess that's the first thing.
I think feeling like an
outsider from early on
has helped me in giving me a
certain naivety around what's
acceptable for me to
say and do or not.
At the same time,
I think it also
made me feel from early
on that there was maybe,
even if it wasn't literal,
but a language barrier to me
and other groups of people.
I could figure out
how to plug myself in,
if I could figure
out the right way
to say the thing I needed to
say to this group of people.
Which has helped in public
speaking and teaching
and stuff.
It's a good way
to think about it
and dialogues cross-culture
is really helpful.
But at the same time,
going into games,
there was a lot of,
I think, doubts.
I perceived a lot of
doubts around my presence
in that space, whether it
was doubts about my validity
as a woman, like, oh, I'm
here because I'm the girl,
or I'm here because
I'm cute, or whatever.
That sense and
that idea of being
around me, it was a really huge
turning point for me, actually,
getting to join the
TED Fellows network
and being a part of a community
where actually a lot of them
are in similar positions
or a lot of outsiders
in their fields and getting
advice back to me about really,
at a certain point,
taking feedback is good
but you also need to come at
it with a core grounding that
had gotten worn down for me.
And it definitely opened
me up to a greater sense
of understanding and
empathy for all minorities
in whatever field.
Because I think that
that's an issue that
affects us all,
having a constant,
you're not really
supposed to be here.
You're only here
because of this.
Whatever that is.
So really being regrounded
and saying almost--
what is that joke around
affirmation style?
"You're good and people
like you" or whatever.
But really, for a while, having
to feel that within myself,
this is what I'm bringing.
This is where I'm coming from.
And this is valuable on its own.
This is not just valuable
in a certain context
in a certain place,
but this is valuable.
And I think that's also allowed
me to be in a better place
to accept feedback.
And I have grown and
evolved much quicker.
But for a while, it
was this downward trend
that I could have seen on
another path stalling out.
And I think that's what
happens to many of us.
SAL YANEZ: Of course.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: You're just
gonna say I'm just tired
and I'm not going
to do it anymore.
SAL YANEZ: Yeah.
And it's difficult for many
of us-- the stereotypes,
the obstacles that one
needs to just jump in order
to get to where we are.
Thank you for sharing that part.
That was extremely
powerful, and I
think it's very inspiring
for the audience here.
How do you think
you are translating
that, all that experience,
everything that you learned
in the video game industry into
Google, especially thinking
about how to open
it up, how to bring
more people into the community,
how to make it more inclusive?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah,
well, so right now
I'm working as a publishing
producer on the Daydream team.
And so really it's an
all new virtual reality,
augmented reality, how are you
going to operate in that space?
Also publishing games and
building out an ecosystem.
And it feels like yet another
moment to set a new precedent
and set a new tone,
which is something,
I think, we're, always hoping
to do in whatever we're
doing at Google,
because they provide
that kind of
opportunity and outlook
towards the world
in what you do.
So I mean, in preparation
for this talk,
I was thinking a lot
about this and that I
think games, what I love
about them within tech
is that they are
really inclusive space.
There are like huge
development communities
now in Brazil and Argentina,
Mexico, and Puerto Rico,
and then growing
scenes in others.
So it's a great way for people
to come in and get skills
and technology that I
think have a lower barrier
than other sectors of tech.
And games themselves
are the space
in which you are invited
to drop your identity,
assume another, pretend
to be someone else,
to play out the worlds that
you want as opposed to the one
that you are in.
Gaming culture is a
whole other thing,
and that's been a big subject
for the last few years.
And I think that we
can separate those out,
games from the gaming culture.
And here is an opportunity
with a new platform,
a new ecosystem, to maybe
make a positive contribution
in setting a new tone
for a new culture.
Another way it's really
impacted me is I'm involved.
We're a growing team and
so I've been thrust in.
This is just now my
first year at Google,
but I think I've
been thrust in really
fast to the interviewing process
and learning about how it's
done here and thinking a lot
about what are ways in which- I
know we're always trying
to remove that bias,
but what are ways in
which it's still present?
Are there ways in
which are questions
around logical thinking biased
towards a specific person
that's come from a specific
privileged background?
I'm not saying that it is.
It's just something
I think about a lot,
and I am shaping the questions
that we ask other people.
So I'm really trying at every
step to ask those questions.
And it's great to
be in a community,
actually, of other Googlers
that accept those questions very
genuinely.
SAL YANEZ: Of course.
And that's great.
And I think it does work at the
dual level study you described.
First is, how do you form
of team here that works
against those unconscious bias?
How can you form all
these perceptions
that allow you to bring
your full self to work?
But then there's also
how, as platform creators,
can you impact the
gaming culture?
I think that one is
even more powerful,
because I think that's where the
vast majority of the problems
are.
Do have any initial
thoughts about how
you were thinking about that?
How do you think
you can positively
impact the gaming culture via
the other platform creation?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yes.
It's a tricky spot that
Google operates in, right?
I think as we're
all familiar with,
which is setting up tools
and structures to be open
and for everyone while at the
same time wanting to present
a certain perspective.
And with Daydream
publishing, we're
really on the edge of
that, because publishing
isn't an operation
Google typically does.
Google builds the
platform and then
people make the stuff
for the platform.
And with publishing,
you're going out
with whatever resource it
is, even if it's just a hey,
we're going to be
really hands on with you
and give you advice
and consultation
from our original partners.
The projects you
choose to do with that
put a perspective out
there in the world.
And so I don't know if I can say
too much more than that, other
than we're constantly
thinking about it.
Well, I guess at Google, you try
to think about things at scale,
but we also try to think
about the tone we're
setting at scale.
What does it mean to pick
this project over this one?
Yeah.
SAL YANEZ: That's great.
I mean, the initial thoughts
are more than useful.
It's about how you think
about the developers.
Where are you sourcing ideas?
Where are your
sourcing products?
What are you supporting?
And then which kind of
ideas they are promoting
within the platform, right?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Right.
SAL YANEZ: So thanks.
Let me make sure that
we can open it up
to questions from the
audience before we finalize.
Because I'm pretty sure
there's a few questions
that people will want to ask.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah.
SAL YANEZ: I want to
give them a chance first.
Do we have our
microphone, by the way?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yes,
Elizabeth has one.
SAL YANEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Is it on?
SAL YANEZ: I don't
think it's on.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Try it again.
SAL YANEZ: Is the
microphone working?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yes, yeah.
SAL YANEZ: It is
now working, yes.
AUDIENCE: So I wrote down a few
questions but I'll just as one.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Oh, cool.
AUDIENCE: One is
something that I
thought of while you were
talking about storytelling.
I feel like text adventures are
a huge place where innovation
has happened, But
it's an old thing.
And I was wondering
if it's something
that you've looked into
or drawn inspiration from.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Oh, definitely.
I mean, it's been huge,
especially drawing
in and empowering
the transgender
community in game development.
A lot of the Twine
community has really
empowered that in
such an awesome way.
So yeah, I think about
how can we build on that.
Is it just time?
Is it that tool is
there now and then
it's just waiting for people
to build up the skill sets?
Or are those voices getting
lost at a certain point?
To me, it's what's the
next step from there?
Because it's definitely
providing a lot of opportunity
for a lot of people that
didn't have it before.
And how can I like enable those
experiences in other mediums
that I'm working on, for sure?
Some of those, yeah,
they're really great.
AUDIENCE: I also really
appreciate the call-out
to the transgender community.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Oh sure.
AUDIENCE: It's important.
AUDIENCE: So I'm curious,
what makes you decide
to leave thatgamecompany?
And what makes you think you
picked VR as the new direction
to pursue after?
And do you think
VR is a bad example
about gaming story like art?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah,
so part of the answer
to thatgamecompany
is easy, which
is it was six years together.
And it's like having a company
together is like a long term
relationship.
And at that point, either
you're growing together,
you're all growing and
changing over six years.
You're either growing together
or you're growing apart,
and we just recognized
that we were growing apart
in what we wanted to do next.
And really, it felt like
putting the round peg
in the square hole, or vice
versa of being together
and constraining ourselves.
So instead, let's separate
and really unchain ourselves
and feel free to
pursue exactly what it
is we wanted to be doing.
One of the things was
originally with thatgamecompany,
the idea Jenova and
I had was to build
an umbrella under which
many studios could operate,
but that's not how
thatgamecompany evolved,
for good reasons.
And I still wanted to.
I still wanted to put
a multiplier effect
on this impact.
And that's part of
also what led me
to Ouya, the
Android-based console
where I was head of developer
relations and content
acquisition.
And it was like the pendulum
swinging all the other way,
the entire way, where at
thatgamecompany, "Journey" was
the last project.
It had been three years,
one game at a time.
And Ouya was working
on 500 games at a time.
And now I'm somewhere
in the middle.
So I got exactly what
I needed out of that
and continue to do so
at Google in interacting
with the wide range
of studios and really
getting to see why things
are the way they are today.
How do we get to
the places of making
this certain type of game or
this certain type of product
and this certain
type of platform.
As far as why VR and AR, part
of it's because it's new.
Yet again, the industry is
at this place where there's
this budding new medium,
and there is very few rules
and definition around it.
So here is a time where we
get to play and figure out
those rules for ourselves.
yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So with
each of these games,
the thatgamecompany games,
you had a specific goal,
an experience you
wanted to evoke.
But the secondary goal
of almost all games
is to make it just
a fun experience.
And you definitely succeeded
on that front as well.
So I was wondering
if there are times
when you have to make
compromises between the story
that you want to tell, the
feeling that you want to evoke,
and things that
make the game fun?
Is there any tension there, or
do they just flow naturally?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: So for me,
I think another word for fun
is engaging.
And I think, well,
with some exception,
there are games
intentionally not fun
or intentionally not engaging.
But when we're
talking about ones
where your goal is
commercial success,
I think engaging
is core to that.
You want you want
people to gravitate
towards it, to play it, to not
drop it, and to get to the end.
So to me, it doesn't feel like
compromising so much as, I
think, it's just
one of the goals
you have to hit as the project.
Probably the thing that feels
like the most compromise
is time and resources.
So just having to
say, this doesn't
feel like the best solution
but we have to move on.
Everyone in games,
there's the phrase,
you don't finish a
game, you abandon it.
That's how it always
feels, no matter what.
You want another question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The microphone
just comes to the area.
I was wondering if you
had any recommendations
for really good storytelling
games that you'd like to share.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Oh man.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah,
that would be good.
Make a co-link-- Kellee's
favorite storytelling games.
Probably two of the
ones in recent history
would be "Papers,
please" and oh my gosh.
Another one.
"Papers, please,"
yeah, is one of them.
Because it really
tells its story.
It's one of those that tells
the story through every aspect
of the game, the
visuals, the music,
the narrative itself, and
then also the mechanics
all place you in this
situation by which you're
receiving the story
through all those elements.
And it does it in a
really fantastic way.
SAL YANEZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you
want another one?
SAL YANEZ: You
can have one more.
AUDIENCE: One of
my other questions
is, how do you deal
with the internet?
The dark underbelly
of the internet
can be really toxic, especially
to [INAUDIBLE] game designers.
Have you dealt with a lot of
vitriol from the internet?
And how do you deal with it?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: So I have not.
I will say I'm not the most
outspoken social person
on social media.
And I think about that a lot.
Am I not outspoken because I
don't want to deal with that?
Is that a reason to not be
outspoken or vice versa?
Or is it that I'm also
burnt on all social media
platforms being designed to
sell you stuff right now?
And that is just really
toxic in and of itself.
That's a whole other
fireside chat maybe.
But yeah, I am being
tracked somewhere.
It's for my activities
in the games industry,
because there's a whole idea
around the social justice
warrior mafia.
Which I love that that's
an insult of a name,
because I think "social justice
warrior" sounds amazing.
I would love that.
But yeah, I haven't
experienced it.
Certainly, many people
very close to me have it,
and that's what I was
thinking about when
I was thinking about the
separation between games
and gaming culture.
Specifically, my
professor, Tracy Fullerton,
very recently went through this.
And now she's just
not on Twitter
and she's not on Facebook.
She's just ghosted
herself from social media.
And I don't know.
That's a loss but she's
still doing her work.
So yeah, I don't know how
we extract these things
from each other.
SAL YANEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So I was curious.
Well, first I wanted to say
that when I was a little kid,
Sierra Online put
out "King's Quest."
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And "King's Quest,"
one of the two creators of that
was Roberta Williams.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it actually never
occurred to me until recently
that women weren't actually a
part of the game development
world.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Right.
Yeah, right.
AUDIENCE: Those were
also my favorite games.
But what I wanted to ask
was, Sony gave you this time
in order to develop this game.
How much freedom
did they give you
to just explore your own
thing versus reign you in
and try to make a
commercially viable product?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: So each game
that we did was more expensive.
So on "Journey," it was really
interesting and educational
for me, because we
had hit a budget
point where suddenly
a lot more people were
focused on the game.
Again, their position towards
third party in general
was pretty hands off.
So I think we were
probably shielded
from quite a lot of it.
But before that, we were
operating at a budget
which is a smart thing to do.
When you're creating
content that's
sort of weird and
different, or at least
different from mainstream or
what's been done in the past,
keeping your budget
low is a good way
to just float under the radar.
Because it won't require
that many approvals and not
that many people have to
look at it to get paid.
So yeah, it was very
educational in that way.
But then getting to
"Journey," we got to see more,
because now we need to charge
a certain price for it.
So it really needs
to have these things.
Now, by that point,
it was our third game,
so our egos were pretty
high and that shielded us.
For better or for worse, we
just didn't accept a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hi, So
I really like when
you were talking about games
being potentially an easier
route into tech for people
from other backgrounds
and also that you came from
theater yourself originally.
Do you feel like there's not
that many easy ways for people
from the arts to get
into tech, or it's
been actually developing to be
a bit more easily accessible,
or that it should be?
Do you have any
thoughts about that?
[INAUDIBLE]
KELLEE SANTIAGO:
Yeah, so I'm not
exposed to every sector
of tech, so there
may be ones where it's
much easier than others.
But for games, I
think fundamentally,
for a lot of
technology companies,
it's important to demonstrate
work on technology.
So games now, there are so
many tools, and web development
as well, to learn how to code.
At the same time,
the specific coding
that you learn for games,
that way of approaching it,
I find just a really
useful practice
in learning programming.
Understanding 3D space is the
best way to learn 3D math.
Approaching it in games was very
different than approaching it
in just a textbook.
So I think it's that practice
of doing and that you can do it,
and also the reward of playing a
game that you made with someone
else is a really great payoff.
And so that creates
its own like, in a way,
game loop and state
of flow through it.
So fundamentally, you're
just practicing and getting
that portfolio built
out, or at least
a body of work you can reference
and take into an interview
somewhere.
Yeah, there was something
else I wanted to say about it,
but I totally forget.
You were asking something else?
AUDIENCE: Is it easy
enough for people
to find those opportunities?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, so the other
part is, I think
this is shifting
now slowly, which
is really exciting to see.
Well, there are definitely
more sectors now applying
game design to their
work, like in politics,
in health, in science.
They're looking.
Here at Google, there
have been more people
from the game industry
hired in the last year
than I think ever.
And we're seeing that at many
other technology companies.
So at the same time, people
with strict art backgrounds,
I feel like there's still
this divide that I would like
to keep bending us towards
having more creative directors
and writers and people that
just have arts backgrounds.
That's very valuable and
contributes something
to all of our work.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah.
SAL YANEZ: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Um.
SAL YANEZ: Just
with the microphone,
please, because
there's a livestream.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So one of the many
pushbacks for Oculus
has been the lack of content.
A year in at Google, what
are we doing to address it?
And how long do you think it
will be for good gaming content
to show up on Daydream or
just for the virtual reality
platform in general?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah, , I mean,
certainly Daydream Publishing
is trying to speed things
along and creating tools.
I mean, there's also
the googly approach
of creating easy to use
tools to make creating
awesome experiences easier.
The other part is the lower
cost of the hardware itself.
So it being based on
smartphones, hopefully
many people that subsidize
through their carriers,
the viewer and controller
itself is at a low price point.
And so that will allow more
people than other platforms
to just have access.
Because every phone is a
development kit as well.
And so that'll just empower
a greater community.
To me, that's always
what it comes down
to is fundamentally that cost.
I mean, that's
what we talk about.
That was something
I learned at Ouya.
And being more exposed to
the hardware side of things,
it's really expensive
to import things
to most South
American countries.
So they don't even have
the hardware to work on.
And then that's true within,
of course, certain populations
in the United States as well.
So the more we can do to
lower that barrier to entry,
the more we enable more types
of people to express themselves.
AUDIENCE: You're saying the
lower cost of hardware itself,
not the cost of development
for a completely
different platform?
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Yeah,
I think that's a base.
SAL YANEZ: So I want make
sure we do finish on time,
because people have meetings.
But I do want to
thank you very much,
Kellee, for sharing your story.
I think your story is very
powerful, very inspiring,
especially for Hispanic
Heritage Month.
It's full of finding
your inspiration,
a sense of belonging,
building communities, bringing
a passion that you have
into a new industry,
and even changing paradigms,
looking at video games as art.
So thank you very
much for sharing it.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Thank you.
SAL YANEZ: Please, give
a big round of applause.
KELLEE SANTIAGO: Thank you.
Thanks for coming out.